and we do just have an update uh in from
the football association breaking news
now this is
uh a statement uh from the fa
we can confirm that ben chilwell and
mason mount
must isolate up to and including next
monday that is the 28th of june
this decision has been taken in
consultation with public health
england the pair were confirmed
overnight as close contacts of
scotland's billy gilmore
after his positive test following last
friday's match
chilwell amount will isolate and train
individually in private areas at
england's training base at st
george's park with the rest of the squad
returning there
after tonight's fixture against the
czech republic at wembley
we will continue to follow all kovid 19
protocols
and the uefa testing regime while
remaining in close contact
with public health england the entire
england squad and staff have lateral
flow tests on monday
and all were again negative as was the
case
with sunday's uefa pre-match pcr tests
further tests will be carried out
as and when appropriate so it looks like
those two are out not just of the final
group four but
also what would be first england's first
game in the final 16 as well